Chris Tucker is a multi-faceted comedian
and actor who gained the world's
attention with this now iconic stand-up
Def Comedy Jam was only the beginning of
Tucker's legendary comedic career one
that he took from the stage to Hollywood
with iconic characters like Johnny Boos
what's up man Smokey you ain't got no
sugar
damn
y'all ain't never got two things that
match Ruby Road boy is huge like fire
we'll start melting ladies because the
boy is hotter than hot
detective James Carter
Egyptian style girl
and those are just some of Chris
Tucker's movies you can see a stand-up
this weekend at The Encore and you can
see him live right now because he joins
us via Zoom Chris Tucker how you doing
I'm good I'm good how are you I'm doing
great I was going to say welcome to Las
Vegas you have a home in Las Vegas yes
yes I call it a rush hour two because
that's when I bought it with Rush Hour 2
money well it worked out for you right
it worked out it worked out are you
already in Las Vegas
I'm here I'm ready to go you're here and
yet you're not here with us in studio
you know what I gotta save all my energy
for the audience you know so I try to
preserve my engine because you know my
show is explosive you know and then this
they gave me a beautiful room so I want
to enjoy this room too the wind got a
they got some great rooms I think they
just remodeled I get it I get it but
this show Chris is watched by dozens
dozens of people every day so oh yeah
what's up Vegas there you go thank you
great to see you tomorrow night and
Saturday night Friday night Saturday
night the wind uh we are excited to see
you too now we've talked about all the
movies you've been in but your roots are
in stand up is there one that you enjoy
doing more than the other acting versus
stand up
live sports you know anything can happen
in at my show and in the movies it's
kind of like you you gotta follow the
story a little bit but you know you got
to be ready for some anything you know
anything so both of them work hand in
hand so they're good talking about being
ready for anything everybody's seeing
what's happened to Chris Rock at the
Oscars recently Dave Chappelle have you
noticed a shift in how audiences respond
to your comedy
yeah I boost up my security man it's
really uh uh no I was joking you know
what he says every comedian is on God
right now you don't know what's gonna
happen I made my stages tall on my stage
so nobody can jump up the stage man it's
like a it's like the Great Wall you
can't jump up on that stage but no it's
it's it's you know it's it's the same
you know comedy is fun it's always gonna
be fun people come to have fun and come
to uh enjoy themselves so you know
it's the same to me I think I like
hearing that and hopefully that's true
as we keep moving past the pandemic
people start to settle down a little bit
all right so you're talking about rush
hour two Rush Hour three was uh way back
in 2007 but I wonder and a lot of people
probably ask you all the time will there
be another one
you know what I would love to do another
one yeah you know me and Jackie are good
friends Jackie Chan we love each other
he calls all the time from Beijing
Beijing and like Chris what are we gonna
do another Rush Hour come on hurry up
I'm getting older you know so I'm like
I'm trying man so if y'all want to see
another Rush y'all call Warner Brothers
and tell them let's get it going okay
we're gonna start a campaign today to
get that going plus you could buy
another house either in Las Vegas or
name the city of your choice I need to
buy another house I need to get another
one for sure
all right what are your favorite things
to do in Las Vegas
you know what I love to go to go
shopping I love to go to the restaurants
I love to go see other shows uh last Big
Show I saw Lionel Richie show that's my
buddy he had a great show right here at
the win so I can't wait to perform
tonight and try to top his show that I
saw that's a little different right
Lionel Richie in your show oh you know
Atlanta's pretty funny though Lionel
Richie's pretty funny but it's a little
different I'm a little bit more edgier
so yeah can people expect edgy I mean
what if they haven't been to see your
stand up before how would you classify
your stand-up
well you can expect anything because uh
you know that's comedy that's the best
comedy uh comedy at its best when you
can expect anything I have certain
things I talk about but then also I have
stuff that just come to my head and I
talk about that uh stuff that come pops
out some stuff that happened at the show
so it's unexpected and it's like I said
it's live so it's nothing better than a
live comedy show like a live basketball
game you don't know what's gonna happen
so and it's drama it's comedy it's funny
I might say something serious uh so it's
private so you come to my show you don't
know a lot about me all right so Friday
Saturday night Encore and you're saving
all your energy for that after that you
come over to my house for dinner all
right I promise man I owe you I owe you
for sure all right hey it is great great
having you with us uh best of luck this
weekend you too man thank you thank you
God bless you guys returns to Las Vegas
with shows at encore theater tomorrow
and Saturday night you can get your
tickets through Ticketmaster and Las
Vegas now will be